vous cherchez un téléphone d'occasion
sur un site de petites annonces
et vous trouvez une bonne main à bon
prix vous vous empressez de rencontrer
le vendeur tester l'appareil
vous voulez dire mais trois semaines
plus tard le téléphone tombe en panne
impossible de le réparer vos recours
pas simple d'abord il ya la garantie du
fabricant mais il faut voir si le
fabricant de la limiter aux premiers
acheteurs
et si c'est le cas en rien à faire de ce
côté ensuite il y a la garantie légale
sauf que l' usage du téléphone ne doit
pas avoir été avisé et ça c'est
difficile à dire puisque vous ne savez
pas ce que l'ancien propriétaire à faire
et son téléphone la loi sur la
protection du consommateur alors est
long elle ne couvre pas de transactions
entre particuliers sauf pour les
véhicules
il reste alors le code civil selon
lequel on est tenu de garantir que ce
que l'on vend est exempt de vice caché
c'est votre dernière option pour suivre
le vendeur de votre téléphone
mais votre défi sera de trouver que le
vice est antérieure à votre achat
le fin mot de l'histoire acheté d'un
particulier permet d'économiser mais
c'est plus risqué